attention jamiroquai attention interview
nul en éponge pour
dans le qinghai alors allons-y pierre
palmade ça tombe sur vous vous devez
partir dans un vaisseau spatial pendant
trois ans est-ce que vous préféré partir
avec elizabeth teissier madame de
fontenay ou nadine de rothschild am est
assiégé dans les étoiles donc je la
trouvais que je l'aimais
qui d'autre madame de fontenay et ses
miss france où nadine de rothschild je
pense elle que je connais pas nadine
nadine alors jean michel jarre si vous
aviez le choix ou préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou
avec un mec très beau avec les deux
peut-être ou peut-être ouest à toi enfin
il faut voir c'est difficile ça dépend
de ses dépens de la laideur et la beauté
s'adresseront à l'air très subjectif la
laideur à la cuisse subie moche et
déprimant moche est quand même très
dirige et à répondre à bon dieu d'alma
vous êtes doucement cette question
remercie alors c'est à vous maintenant
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore
ou oui oui le risque et ils ont eu le
désir du sco mariage ni même le plus con
amour merci le plus con je vais te dire
c'est quelqu'un puis gelé
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a reconnu pendant
les rapports et qui j'étais rentré comme
j'ai la personne était un peu embrumé
moi aussi et c'est pendant les rapports
la personne a ouvert les yeux fait au
pur ball me
un petit toit déstabiliser jean michel
est ce que vous savez vous lécher la
langue
non non je n'essaye à partir
d'aujourd'hui non mais c'est d'abord
utilisé le riz ll62 vous lécher la
langue abc si on peut l on peut bien sûr
concours bah ouais je sais je sais en
fait il faut s'aider du palais ouais non
pas le vous lécher la moustache josé lui
laisser la pâte c'est pas dur j'avais
mes hanches et la langue c'est un peu
con mais c'est pas génial xavi lui est
bien attention palmade nous sommes seuls
qui tous les deux vous et moi d'accord
bloqué l'hiver dans un chalet il fait
très froid il ya trois mètres de neige
on a rien à bouffer je meurs de froid
vous mourrez de faim
vous me manger vous commencez par quoi
demander qu'est ce qui est le meilleur
dans ce meilleur dans dix jours
ce fils jours on a une bonne 38 saut un
mot qui sonne dollars 10 ans et vosges à
le bas des oreilles c'est pas mal d'eau
douce à pour commencer
dit ryan à celles là c'est là les durs
jean michel vous préféreriez être
réincarné en slip de françois hollande
ah je sais que françois bayrou ou de
nicolas sarkozy ça c'est très très dur
ce qui est bien c'est qu'elle est le
plus propre que choisir dans quel ce
qu'ils voulaient être réincarné que vous
savez que vous serez réincarné en slip
joue suicide si je me suicide avant
avant les incarner apparemment quand on
se suicide n'est pas ringard des dons
alors êtes-vous pierre palmade vous
préféreriez être incarnée en slip de
françois hollande de françois bayrou ou
de nicolas sarkozy
alors comment comment on peut savoir
qu'elle est propre nicolas sarkozy lui
seul que je connais ouais donc il
m'envoya que françois bayrou le matin à
face sans slip
bien alors jean michel jarre ça tombe
sur vous vous préféreriez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion
john lennon un shot à bout portant
janis joplin une audi no vers dose ou
comme john bonham le batteur de led zep
qui est mort étouffé dans son vomi
ça c'est pas une question nul sauf le
dernier k way dirait john lennon john
lennon mois que ce soit rapide à bout
portant
ouais ouais et vous voilà je ne voudrais
pas donner des idées aux gens mais
assassiné j'ai joint jeudi à cannes
j'avions je suis portrait paraît est une
ode et c'est pas terrible si vous étiez
en vente dans un sex-shop vous seriez
quoi je parle
c'est tout ben vous un truc flatteur
blatter jeudi virilement facteurs
d'accord
jean michel vous seriez quoi nous étions
avant dans un sex-shop un mode d'emploi
à temps d'y penser ça tombe sur vous
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
un doigt supplémentaire alors ou alors
quoi un sexe évidemment elles soient
réglementaires de sexe mariées 2 non
c'est pas mal ben oui un oeil à neuss et
ça fait un peu mon jeu tandis qu'un sac
supplémentaires sont énormes à cod
jean-michel un sexe d'homme en plus ou
un sexe de femme avait une bonne
question ça serait pas mal d'avoir un
sexe et d'hermann les deux ouais les
deux et vous moi j'ai déjà les deux